for some, the tree of life is an apple tree from
biblical stories, for others it is a
Scandinavian dubtor or a Chinese
peach, and for us it is a cherry, a whole cosmos
from which unfolds the
life of the city filled with the heat of the steppe,
this is our Melitopol,
once the Scythians lived in these bare steppes, and
centuries later the Cossacks came and
built their  defensive redoubt
frosts in winter heat in summer lack of
drinking water lack of water in general all this
lasted until one doctor Andrii
Korvatskyi began to look for ways to
overcome drought avitaminosis and the
Franco-Dutch landowner
Andriy Philibert did not bring in seedlings of cherry trees
and small sugar, as these lands were then called,
Melitopol came to life  is it not for nothing that they call the
cherry capital of Ukraine
Melitopol cherry tree
every two
r of the city even the four-hundred-year-old
Melitopol oak has become the
cherry tree of 105 peoples but one community
in it together we learn to care for
each other and for Mylitopol not because someone
forces it but simply because it is ours that was
shown to the Russians  the occupier  m and how
to gather for protests even when the
communication is jammed
and how to win back the captured mayor
and
send the imposed ones after the Russian ship as a hymn
to sing Looking at the barrel of the machine gun they
sang so much That the occupiers probably
remember it better than their own
[  music]
over Dmytro Dontsov, who more than 100
years ago developed the Ukrainian
national idea that we, Ukrainians, Greeks, Germans,
Karaites, Bulgarians, Jews, Tatars, Armenians,
Orthodox Catholics, Mennonites, Jews,
like cherries from the same bunch, are always
together and never for an hour did they
even know about the hospitable reception of our partisans,
because  this is not someone else's war, but ours, the war of our
land, our Melitopol, and the day will come
when the Tavrian trumpets will play again, the
stolen Scythian gold will return to the museums, and we will
all go home, which ends
only at the borders of the city and not at the house,
to all those little things that make our
life ours, and we will gather on
Victory Square or in the park and we will eat the
famous Karaite pies and restore
order in the city so that the spirit
Okupansky didn't have any left And then we'll pick
cherries and go to the sea I'll pick or hear
Cyrillic or to a stone grave
Who are we the
berries of one tree of life we'll be filled with the
steppe sun we'll get a cherry
tan and we'll build the city again and with
new strength we'll fall in love with it
again because  this is our city this is our
honey-cherry Melitopol and this
[music]